desde hace 35 años angélica huamán
trabaja en sembríos de tubérculos afirma
que en perú los gobiernos tienen
abandonados a los agricultores quienes
representan a casi un tercio del
electorado en enero y según ella nada
cambiará esta vez ahorita ni con keiko
ni con pedro gacio no el sip o lo que
se ve olite que es mucha violencia dice
una cosa dice otra cosa ya hemos visto
esto de la señora fujimori buenos papá
que fue presidente en una primera etapa
pero igual no quisieron nada por los
agricultores en el distrito de los
olivos de la capital peruana isaías mal
con un administrador hotelero está
desempleado él es uno de los tres
millones de limeños que perdió su
trabajo por la pandemia del cob y 19
isaías trata de subsistir preparando
hamburguesas que reparte a domicilio
no tengo una confianza en tanto ni en
castillo por el tema de que está
relacionado con el comunismo y puede ser
una dictadura y en el caso de keiko
fujimori tampoco por el tema de la
corrupción no hay una garantía para
nosotros ahorita en la actualidad la
campaña presidencial de pedro castillo y
keiko fujimori dividió a los peruanos de
manera más radical es un poco un poco
difícil
y determinar el timing o sea cuánto va a
pasar hasta que emerjan las cosas pero
creo que el camino en el que está el
perú en este momento es el camino que ya
transitó chile y que está en este
momento transitando colombia es decir
con lapsos de tiempo con intensidades
diferentes hay un sector que quiere
cambios profundos
esta semana el gobierno peruano reveló
que el registro de fallecidos por kobe
19 era 25 veces inferior a la cifra real
lo que hace de perú el país con la
mortalidad más alta del mundo por
coronavirus otra señal de la fragilidad
política que arrastra la nación andina
desde hace muchos años